fabien on est on est très très bien
ouais c'est bien tu es là où l'âge tout
un peu plus à quoi ou au voilà je suis
là j'étais en train de réfléchir en fait
pour je cherche une idée testud fait
dans un cube
ben je cherche une idée pour la
prochaine vidéo une idée d'un trop parce
que comme la vidéo c'est une side cub3
je dis je vais chercher dans le cube 3
je garde les bras croisés parce que
j'aime beaucoup on peut avoir les bras
croisés et ne pas bouger comme si
j'étais un faux hockey de me remettre
maintenant
ouais d'accord juste dit dès que dès que
je suis prêt je te dis en fait d'accord
voilà j'ai mis en culture aux fermes
balle mal à se lancer
on va dans le noir on recopie beaucoup
[Musique]
bonjour je suis fabien olicard oui
c'était l'intro que vous m'avez proposer
la moins dure à mettre en place mais
c'est vous qui proposait aussi toujours
pour les prochaines aujourd'hui on va
parler d'un cast et dont vous me parlez
depuis depuis cet été carrément mais que
je connaissais déjà depuis très
longtemps qui s'appelle inside cube mais
cube marqué comme un carré mais cube
vous m'en parlez à chaque fois dans les
commentaires j'en ai discuté avec vous
parfois par mail parce que c'est un
casse tête qui dura présenté comme ça à
l'image donc j'étais mieux que ça je me
suis équipé de toute la gamme de inside
cube et je vais vous parler de pourquoi
comment quand ouais c'est compliqué à
faire en vidéo parce que le principe du
cube c'est que tout se passe à
l'intérieur et c'est un cube qu'on fait
à l'aveuglé le principe il est mortel
vous avez une
il est ici et il ya différents plateaux
à l'intérieur cette pour être précis et
elle doit retomber là tu es forcément là
je vous fait voir un fassi lundi
vous savez ici ou est ce que va
apparaître la bio départ et où est ce
qu'il ya un trou qui va la faire placer
des claques tôt à un autre qui va la
faire passer d'un plateau à un autre
loïc est ce que tu crois que je leur
ouvre celui ci pour leur faire voir
comment ça se passe peut-être c'est
mieux ok merci de cette réflexion
pertinente et pertinents bhl est ce que
tu peux me passer un petit louvre
lettres peut-être quelque chose comme ça
bah je sais quoi je vais le prendre
parce que comme il est là merci le hic
du coup cela j'aime être avec toi je te
le rend visible comme des enfants qu'ils
viennent te donner un petit jeu est-il
garde fait c'est pour moi merci merci
beaucoup
donc là déjà ici on a un des bouts de
chemin du labyrinthe on voit bien que la
big elle doit faire ce trajet la traque
ici on a le plateau numéro 6 le plateau
numéro 5
le plateau numéro 4 le numéro 3 ya un
suspense terrible qui s'installe parce
qu'après le 3 il ya le 2 et après le 2
tout le monde attend le loïc 1 1
exact correct loïc à l'intérieur du cube
vous avez ce magnifique labyrinthe donc
la vie commence ici elle commence ici à
l'endroit en fait qui permet de la
bloquer on l'a des blocs et elle part et
vous devait l'emmener pour qu'elle
puisse ressortir ici de l'autre côté
c'est à dire qu'elles ressortent de ce
trou et vous vous lui faites faire la
fin du chemin du labyrinthe pour qu'elle
arrive juste la voilà à quoi ressemble
l'intérieur d'inside pub c'est
extrêmement fun à faire en vidéo serait
pas tellement d'intérêt vraiment je
pense pas parce que parce qu'on va à me
voir bouger le cube dans tous les sens
je veux faire un tout petit peu mais
n'est pas plus que ça mais par contre il
ya des versions mon gars elles sont
justes pousse alors aussi pourquoi je
suis content d'en parler parce que il ya
deux choses qui sont hyper original déjà
c'est une boîte française qui fait ça on
a envie de guerre cocorico ou pas oui
mais pourquoi tu ne l'as pas fait
cocorico correct et la deuxième chose
c'est que c'est quelque chose de
novateur qui n'existait pas jusque là
c'est pas du tout une grosse société qui
a fait ça en fait c'est un passionné de
castets qui a créé le sien est
aujourd'hui avec la technologie
d'imprimantes 3d etc
ça rendait la chose vraiment possible là
vous devez bien le voir de ce côté là
vous avez tous les plans d'un côté comme
de l'autre pour le faire dans un chemin
ou dans un autre dans un sens ou dans un
titre tout la bielle et ici ça veut dire
que sur le plan correspond plateau où
aller c'est à dire cela elle est
exactement positionner là donc il va
falloir que je la des blocs pour
l'emmener sur la gauche et ensuite que
je fasse un coup vers le haut pour
l'emmener là puis la droite
là elle va tomber elle directement tout
seul puis que je continue à les faire
table chemin comme c'est un petit peu en
escargot pour qu'elle tombe dans le
petit renfoncement qu'on voit ici
qui va la faire tomber dans le deuxième
plateau pour vous puissiez encore mieux
comprendre je prends en de la nouvelle
gamme mais tant ils sont tous comme ça
c'est à dire qu'ils sont pas tous rose
mais ils ont tous les coins arrondis
c'est beaucoup plus agréable à manipuler
et leur ouverture aussi est beaucoup
plus simple puisque la sur le côté on
peut juste tirer et tout vient
directement
donc ça c'est bien pour ceux qui peuvent
s'ouvrir c'est pas le cas de tous et on
a l'habitude ici au départ juste vers
ici sur le premier plateau vous voyez
une petite flèche c'est l'endroit où
elles se situent actuellement par
rapport au plan je vous ai dit si la
version simple l'habit était là elle est
partie de là il fallait la faire monter
pour qu'elle a émis 6 qu'elle tombe dans
le trou et ensuite lui faire enchaîner
les différents plateaux pour qu'elle
arrive jusqu'au dernier à ressortir là
c'est la toute première version c'est la
version novices de la nouvelle gamme et
forcément il ya quatre plateaux c'est
fait pour apprendre à jouer une fois
qu'on lui a fait faire le trajet dans un
sens évidemment on peut le mettre dans
l'autre sens pour lui faire le trajet
dans l'autre sens et on récupère
également les plans de la même manière
là où ça devient cool et à la limite on
pourrait se faire des battles à ces
possibles sur la chaîne plutôt que de
l'explication de casse tête comme on
fait d'habitude sur les différentes
gammes maintenant il ya trois grosses
séries la série aux novices et la plus
simple il y en a 3 2 dans le super
fascine le faisable et le bien plus dure
on va dire un peu plus dur c'est le
orange d'aquin dessous très jolie pareil
nouveau les coins arrondis et c'est la
série on va dire le cube original moi
j'ai commencé avec le rouge je crois que
c'est le premier qui a été produit parce
qu'on me l'avait offert un anniversaire
il ya cinq ans je crois 4 5 ans et puis
alors ça c'est la série phantom la série
phantom c'est quoi c'est toute la série
sam à nancy la faut que vous en parle
aussi d où la série phantom c'est une
série ou à l'intérieur du cube dessus
bien loïc 1 ghaibi c'est celle tombée à
manipuler mais il y aussi le deuxième
but qui est emprisonné dans une prison
du coup plutôt de type public est comme
ça tu dis bah c'est pas gênant mais en
fait quand une manipuler que tu écoute
toi le bruit de ta [ __ ] entend le bruit
de la deuxième billes et en clair il ya
un mot technique pour ça on dit que ça
fait bien chier parce que tu sais pas du
tout en tournée c'est très très dur mais
aux fantômes peuvent se rajouter aussi
des options telles que celui ci il est
juste infernale
c'est un cube tant qu'à un labyrinthe
que vous le sortir un jour sortir alors
le premier casse-tête
c'est d'ouvrir le packaging celui ci
c'est le mortal c'est à dire il a cette
classe au à l'intérieur il a une bille
fantôme il n'a aucun tracé donc on peut
pas du tout savoir comment fonctionne le
tracé hockey et en plus il ne s'ouvre
pas voilà celui ci je n'ai toujours pas
réussi à le faire je ne sais pas combien
il ya de personnes qui ont réussi à le
faire mais je doute qu'il y en ait
beaucoup c'est en fait le truc qui est
terrible c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand je
le reprends je me souviens même plus de
là où j'en étais et j'en ai acheté un
nouveau pourtour offert à 0 et vient
déjà de le manipuler c'est quand même
très con ça c'est un autre fantôme alors
lui c'est différent il à une ville
fantôme dedans et au lieu d'avoir un
plan il a ça je vous faire voir ça en
gros plan amuse toi mon pote à
comprendre ce que ces glyphes veux lui
dire et tu pourras peut-être
à ton tour le réseau à celui ci subit si
j'aimerais vous en parler celui ci c'est
trop cool c'est des fans de l'insight
cube comme moi qui ont créé sa voix qui
ont créé en fait ils se sont rapprochés
du site internet du créateur en lui
demandant si on pouvait créer un cube de
fans et il a dit ok une seule condition
c'est que vous réutilise y ait des
moules qui sont déjà existant pour les
autres c'est ce qui doit coûter cher à
fabriquer j'imagine c'est le moule de
départ donc ils ont dit graves dont il a
fourni tous les moules qui existaient et
ils ont fait leurs propres compilations
ils ont choisi leurs propres couleurs
plutôt le violet donc ça c'est
l'ancienne version à celle avec avec les
bords et l'autre système d'ouverture
ils ont créé celui ci donc il ya un fan
cube où je trouve ça cool que la
communauté et créer son propre cube sur
leur site internet on peut tenter de
battre des records
je vous mettrais un lien dans la
description sur le site original inside
the cube et donc vous avez tous les
différents trucs mais il ya aussi la
partie où tu peut soumettre une vidéo
parce que pour valider un record c'est
pas dur tu envoies une vidéo qui n'a pas
été trafiqués au niveau du mouvement et
cetera
on s'en fiche un peu de la qualité il
faut juste que ça rende bien et faut que
tu aurais zoll veut le cube
vous allez voir des trucs d'une d'une
déprime ans dessus de petits jeunes qui
te quitte explosent des cubes en
quelques secondes les mêmes les novices
je vais pas aussi vite que sinon il y
aurait déjà ma vidéo d'ailleurs qu'ils
seraient là bas mais c'est ouf je vous
recommande d'aller voir ça si vous
voulez regarder des vidéos un petit peu
style et ça c'est très stylé toute
manière le côté records ou le côté
battle
c'est tout l'intérêt de le faire en
vidéo c'est excellent de le faire seule
c'est trop cool
j'avais pas éprouver de plaisir comme ça
depuis le rubik's cube sur sur ce genre
de de castets réutilisables
c'est même pas un casse tête d'ailleurs
pour moi c'est plus un jeu voyait un peu
comme le rubik's cube mais bruel fois en
vidéo en faisant soi des records ou des
battles dites moi dans les commentaires
vous êtes les bienvenus c'est un peu
chez vous quand même les commentaires
parler discuter soilly créatif et ai pu
faire ça s'est passé ça non comme ça je
pourrais le maître mot en premier ça ça
me plaît non mais voilà vous pouvez en
parler dans les commentaires je serais
vraiment les coûts de ça je sais pas
trop comment on pourrait mettre ça en
scène donc je vous attends sachez aussi
que vous pouvez avoir comme moi si vous
écrivez sur le site internet du créateur
il envoie des petits stickers comme ça
ça sert à quoi ça sert en fait à
positionner différemment
les tablettes à l'intérieur et tu te
remets un nouveau parcours et du coup tu
as un nouveau cube ça c'est vraiment
très très cool aussi
tu peux te mettre d'autres face il ya
plein de versions différentes
il y en a pour tous les goûts différents
ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais
vous en faire gagner un petit peu comme
d'habitude comme dans tous les cas state
avec les stickers vous mais cette
photo-là sur instagram vous lisez dans
les commentaires et je fais le tirage au
sort au plus tard mardi prochain donc
dans moins d'une semaine dans six jours
loïc est ce que tu as des questions à
propos des cubes oui alors qu on appelle
ça un cube
ah ben ça c'est une très très bonne
question alors je serai en spectacle
demain pendant trois jours à mulhouse
avec le spectacle singularité il ya le
bien et dans la description comme dans
toutes les villes de tourner ensuite je
serai au salon de colmar en dédicace ce
dimanche et je serai le 2 décembre
spectacle au casino d'enghien les bains
et je serai le 13 décembre à sélestat un
spectacle et après je prends un petit
peu de sa réponse est que ce qui a bien
sûr merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo vous avez toutes les infos sur
tout ce dont j'ai parlé dans la
description n'oubliez pas de mettre un
pouce en l'air ici je vous mets le
casse-tête de la semaine dernière ici je
vous mets une autre vidéo qui devrait
vous plaire
pensez à vous abonner c'est important à
très bientôt ciao